[Music]  our team is the heart soul of this very  Beach protect obey at all cost what I  don't know what that means  every one of the briefs is talking about  you guys this is Victoria Lee the new  owner of the Humber Club I know that the  club's probably not your scene but  standing in the future all the bad [ __ ]  happening on our Beach started once you  look over at my ball say we need to go  over there and check it out I've all day  thinking he's right the truth what a  [ __ ] your ball sound like three year old  girls I don't know man that's just how  they talk but they're wise we gotta go  undercover you might knit cap undercover  yeah little to undercover you think I'm  a drug dealer  honey look at me oh don't even start  [Music]  [ __ ] my card big pair of them already  why are we in the morgue I'm not coming  for you now now we hi we're doctors are  empty why'd you pick natural I love it  it's just don't know dead man's fat stop  being a baby  that's it I'm out  you